I want you to think about the last time
you try to improve something.
Maybe it was a presentation at work.
You read through the slides and your
instinct was to add a chart or a
footnote or a new slide to explain the
previous one.
This is a tendency so automatic, so
deeply embedded in the way we think
that we don't notice it. We add. We
rarely subtract. And that instinct, the
one that feels so smart and so
productive, may be one of the biggest
blind spots we have.
Let me explain.
At the University of Virginia, an
engineer named Leidy Klotz has spent
years studying this tendency. He calls
it subtraction neglect. It's our
automatic impulse to solve a problem by
addition
even when the better solution is to take
something away. The story of how Leidy
came to understand this begins in a
college exam room with a professor named
Viscomi and a chalkboard showing two
numbers. When Leidy was an undergraduate
engineering student, he was struggling
to master mechanics, the branch of
physics that deals with objects at rest
and in motion.
>> And my approach to mechanics was figure
out how to solve the problems that I've
been assigned for homework, learn that
specific problem, and try to cram as
many of those into my brain as possible
so that when the exam came about, I'd be
more likely to have a an exact replica
of the problem that was on the exam
already accessible in my brain.
>> It wasn't working. He was carrying a C
average. For the first time in his life,
he was in danger of failing a course. If
that happened, he would have to delay
his degree, ask his parents to pay extra
tuition, or change his major entirely.
So, before the third exam, he tried
something radical. He stopped cramming.
He stripped everything away.
He realized that much of introductory
mechanics boils down to one equation.
Newton's second law of motion, force
equals mass times acceleration.
He realized that if he understood that
one thing deeply enough,
he could work through most of what the
exam threw at him.
>> I stopped memorizing dozens of other
equations and tangential ideas. I didn't
need to know a bunch of forces and
masses and accelerations. I just needed
to remember that formula, F equals MA.
>> He walked into the exam that day
carrying fewer things in his head than
any of his classmates. Sometime later,
Professor Viscomi handed back the exams.
He wrote two numbers on the chalkboard,
a 98
and a 47.
Then he looked at Lyddy
and smirked.
>> Everybody assumed that I had gotten the
47. My classmates were playfully jeering
me. And I'm sitting there thinking about
like, okay, now that I've failed out of
engineering, what will my major be? And
when I got my test back, I realized why
he had smirked, and it was because I had
earned the 98.
>> Lyddy was ecstatic. But more than that,
he was confused. He had done better by
reducing the things he was keeping in
his head,
by subtracting.
It was a start of a long journey to
understand why we systematically
overlook the power of subtraction
and what this costs us. Years later,
Lyddy saw the same principle in a
playroom. He was building a bridge out
of Duplo blocks with his 3-year-old son,
Ezra.
The support towers were of different
heights.
The bridge wouldn't span because they
weren't level. Lyddy's instinct was to
add a block to the shorter tower.
But before he could act,
Ezra did.
>> Ezra had already removed a block from
the taller tower. So, whereas my impulse
had been to add to the short support, in
that moment I realized that it wasn't
the only way to create a level bridge.
>> Lyddy brought the the problem to
colleagues, to students, to a professor
he describes as a genius.
He wanted to see who would think to
subtract. Everyone added. It was then
that he began to understand, this isn't
a quirk of personality. It's something
that happens inside virtually all of us.
So, he designed a series of experiments.
In research published in Nature in 2021,
Leidy and his team showed volunteers a
digital grid of colored squares and
asked them to make it symmetrical.
You could add squares or remove them.
Both approaches worked.
Most people chose to add.
The moment subtraction was pointed out
as an option, people took it. The
problem was subtraction didn't occur to
people as a possibility. This pattern
appeared everywhere Leidy looked.
He asked people to improve a short
essay.
Only 17% subtracted words. The other
83%?
They made it longer.
Strunk and White's, The Elements of
Style, the most assigned writing
textbook in American classrooms for
decades, carries a famous directive.
Omit needless words.
That advice has been on syllabi for
generations. And yet, people handed an
essay and told to improve it, still
reached for more words, not fewer.
The same pattern held in recipes. When
volunteers were asked to improve a
five-ingredient dish,
only two out of 90 removed an
ingredient.
When given loops of musical notes and
asked to improve them, people were three
times more likely to add notes, rather
than take them away. Leidy built one
more experiment inspired by a
long-running disagreement with his wife,
who likes to stuff family travel
schedules with activity. He created a
fictional itinerary for a day in
Washington, D.C.
14 hours. The White House, the National
Cathedral, the Old Post Office, the
Lincoln Memorial, the Vietnam Veterans
Memorial, a a museum, shopping, lunch at
a five-star bistro. Just the travel time
between all those stops, assuming
optimal DC traffic, would exceed two
hours.
Volunteers could rearrange activities,
add new ones, or remove items.
>> Even with this jam-packed itinerary,
only one in four participants removed
activities from the packed original.
>> And the rest?
>> Well, some rearranged, but most added.
>> They added to a schedule that was
already physically impossible to
complete. So, all this raises a critical
question. Why? Part of the answer might
be biological. At the University of
Michigan, psychologist Stephanie Preston
has spent her career studying what she
calls acquisitiveness, our drive to get
and keep things. In one study,
volunteers were shown over 100 objects
on a screen. Bananas, coffee mugs,
extension cords, but also empty 2-liter
bottles, used sticky notes, outdated
newspapers. They were asked whether they
wanted to acquire each item virtually.
People wanted to accumulate dozens of
objects, things they had no use for.
Then came the real test. They had to
whittle everything down to fit into a
digital grocery bag on the screen.
>> A lot of participants failed to get it
down to a single bag.
>> Neuroscience also has something to say
about our tendency to be acquisitive.
When we acquire things, even used sticky
notes, it activates the brain's reward
pathway. This is the same system
stimulated by cocaine.
Adding feels like a win, like progress,
like abundance. Subtraction feels like a
loss.
And humans, as any behavioral economist
will confirm, are deeply averse to
losses.
If our biology is already pushing us
toward addition, our culture applies
even more pressure. Consider what we
celebrate. We build plaques for people
who construct skyscrapers.
We name buildings after donors. We hold
ribbon cuttings for new hospitals and
new highways.
>> It's so much easier to get a donation
for somebody to create a building that
has their family's name on it than to
donation for removing something or for
even for something that doesn't come
with this big physical reminder of the
person's generosity.
>> Politicians want to tout a new amenity.
Something tangible, something they can
point to.
You cannot cut a ribbon on a decrepit
building that has been removed. This
pattern stretches back to the earliest
days of human civilization. Monumental
architecture, the pyramids of Egypt, the
ziggurats of Mesopotamia. They are
literally defined by the fact that their
scale exceeded any practical function.
These were structures that added well
beyond what was necessary. The leaders
who commissioned them gained status.
Addition, in the deep grammar of
civilization
has been the language of power.
>> Subtracting is more work. It's more
mental work. It's more kind of steps as
we're talking about it. And there's less
to show for it. And so after you do all
this extra work, you have less evidence
because the thing that you've done is by
definition disappeared.
>> Lidwell saw this at his own university.
The University of Virginia asked for
suggestions on how to improve.
Out of 750 ideas, fewer than 10%
suggested taking something away.
People wanted more study abroad grants,
more mental health services, more
housing. Someone requested a new ice
arena.
>> Surely there was untapped potential
because out of 750 ideas for changing
the university, fewer than 10% suggested
taking something away.
>> And there's a logic to this.
If you walk into an organization and
propose cutting things, you're
challenging someone's pet project,
someone's baby. You'll make enemies. But
if you propose adding something, there's
almost no social risk, and you'll get to
say, "This will make things better."
Removing something also requires you to
deeply understand how a system works, to
figure out what it is that is redundant
or unnecessary.
The result, in organizations everywhere,
is accumulation. A pileup of programs,
initiatives, even meetings that nobody
questions.
Subtraction sometimes requires an
external push. Call it an external
executioner. Consider the Embarcadero
Freeway in San Francisco. Built after
World War
II, it was a massive, double-decker
concrete structure stretching more than
a mile along the eastern waterfront,
blocking access to the bay.
In the mid-1980s, planners proposed
tearing it down. Voters rejected it. For
every person who wanted the freeway
removed, two wanted to keep it.
A Pulitzer Prize-winning San Francisco
Chronicle columnist named Herb Caen
wrote that tearing down the freeway was,
quote, "An even worse idea than building
it." The Planning Commission moved on.
Then, on October 17th, 1989, the Loma
Prieta earthquake struck.
>> The earthquake killed more than 60
people and injured thousands. And then
it also gave people a view of what life
would be like if you didn't have the
Embarcadero, cuz the Embarcadero didn't
collapse during the earthquake, but it
was rendered unusable for a while. And
so people saw that they found other ways
to get around the city, um and that it
didn't kind of totally ruin life in San
Francisco to not have the Embarcadero.
>> The earthquake provided the push.
The freeway came down. The waterfront
came back. Housing increased, jobs
increased, traffic rerouted without
catastrophe.
>> By 2000, it was hard to find anyone who
thinks ripping down the freeway was a
bad idea.
>> It took a disaster to make the
possibility of subtraction visible. To
prove that what had been removed was
not, in fact, necessary.
Science suggests we don't have to wait
for a crisis. We can build structures
that force subtraction into our
decision-making.
One of Leidy's most practical tools is
what he calls the stop doing list.
We all keep to-do lists. A stop doing
list operates on the same logic, except
instead of adding tasks, you catalog the
things you're going to quit.
>> If you're going to add new stuff to your
day and assuming you're already at
capacity, you need to also figure out
what you're going to take away.
>> For Leidy, one useful application is
what he calls stop editing. He reads a
great deal of student writing. When he
picks up a rough draft, the temptation
is to mark every change he would want to
make.
>> I'll set a limit. I'll say, "Okay, give
this student the 10 most important
comments for this piece of writing." And
it works really well. I mean, it saves
me time, one, but it also kind of
rewards students who do more, right? So,
if the student gives you a really
polished piece of writing, I still force
myself to come up with 10 ways to make
it better, whereas if somebody doesn't
put as much time in and gives you this
really rough first draft, I don't spend
all my time getting that to the same
place that the the other piece of
writing is.
>> The same principle applies to laws that
govern us. By some measures, the number
of laws on the books grow faster than
the economy. Some places now require
legislators, when proposing a new law,
to identify an existing law that they
want to remove. By making it a rule, you
make it easier to subtract. You make it
socially acceptable
to propose subtraction.
In medicine, subtractions save lives. At
Johns Hopkins University, researcher
Peter Pronovost was studying
catheter-related infections. Catheters,
thin plastic tubes used to draw blood or
deliver medication, are ubiquitous in
hospitals and one of the most common
sources of infection. These infections
were causing roughly 30,000 deaths in
the United States every year, about as
many as car crashes. The insertion
process was complicated, dozens of
steps, each requiring judgment.
Pronovost's insight was to simplify.
>> Pronovost and his team considered all of
this complexity, but then they proposed
a very simple recipe. They They gave a
checklist. Wash their hands with soap,
clean the patient's skin with
antiseptic, put sterile drapes over the
entire patient, wear a sterile mask,
hat, gown, and gloves, and put a sterile
dressing over the catheter site.
>> Five steps. Pronovost had made what was
essential stand out.
And people stopped dying. Some of the
most powerful examples of subtraction
come from design. In 1927, Anna
Keichline had an insight about building
materials that would change construction
forever. She was the first female
licensed architect in Pennsylvania, a
serial inventor.
She changed construction by noticing
something everyone else had overlooked.
Before Keichline, building blocks were
solid, dense, heavy.
She asked, "Do they need to be?"
>> By creating the the hollow block, you
remove half the material, which of
course makes it less expensive and
easier to build with, and less fuel to
transport. And then these hollow blocks
also provide more insulation because of
the air voids that are in the blocks.
>> Her key brick was cheaper, lighter,
insulated better, and was less prone to
fire. The hollow concrete masonry unit,
the direct descendant of her invention,
is one of the most commonly used
building materials on planet Earth.
Then And the Strider bike. For nearly a
century, children's bicycles were loaded
with additions, training wheels, fake
tires, contraptions attaching a child's
bike to a parent's bike like a caboose.
Then someone asked,
"What if we subtract the pedals and the
drivetrain entirely?"
>> The way they work, they're small bikes,
but they're not propelled by chains and
pedals, but by toddlers striding with
their legs. Once my my son is since aged
out of the Strider bike, and once he
decided it was time for his big kid
bike, we didn't have to bother with
training wheels. He already knew how to
balance.
>> By removing what everyone assumed was
essential, designers made the bike
ridable by children as young as a year
and a half.
They found a whole new market. And they
eliminated the need for training wheels.
But even when we do subtract, there is a
final problem.
Noticeability. When you add something,
everyone can see it.
When you subtract something,
the evidence, by definition,
disappears. Back in the 1970s, an
aerospace engineer named Marion Rudy had
an idea.
Use air to provide cushioning in running
shoes.
Less material inside the shoe, more
performance on the road.
Shoe companies kept turning him down.
They couldn't see what he was offering.
He finally reached Nike.
Phil Knight took him out for a run, felt
the difference, and agreed.
But still,
nobody could see it.
>> They had this kind of seminal shoe, the
the Air Max 1, and those shoes were one
of the the first models that actually
displayed the air. So, they have the
little window on the side, so you could
see, "Hey, in fact, there's air in
here."
>> Nike didn't just sell air cushioning.
They made the absence of material
visible. They cut a window into the sole
of the shoe, so you could see what was
no longer there.
Marie Kondo built an empire on a version
of the same refrain.
For years, the default advice for
tidying a home was to identify what you
no longer wanted, sort through the
clutter, discard what doesn't fit. Kondo
flipped the question entirely.
Forget what you want to get rid of.
Focus only
on what you want to keep.
>> Her core message is sparking joy. She
said, "Keep what sparks joy and get rid
of everything else." And so, she's kind
of steering us around Massa version
there, um because she's focusing us on
this, you know, this future vision of
the the tidy space.
>> The outcome is identical. What changes
is where your attention goes.
And that, psychologists will tell you,
changes everything. When Bruce
Springsteen recorded Darkness on the
Edge of Town in 1978, he wrote more than
50 songs.
Only 10 made the record. The songs he
removed were not bad. Some became
massive hits the moment they left his
hands.
Patti Smith's Because the Night reached
number 13. The Pointer Sisters' Fire hit
number two.
Springsteen gave away top 20 singles.
He had yet to place one there himself.
>> He talks about this album as his samurai
record, all stripped down for fighting,
and those are his exact words. So, he's
going for this really stripped down
aesthetic he thought would kind of
revolutionize the way music was heard.
>> Liedy's favorite song on that record is
Racing in the Street. It was the lullaby
he sang to Ezra. Its opening line, "I
got a '69 Chevy with a 396."
Compare that with the opening line of
Greetings from Asbury Park, New Jersey,
Springsteen's debut.
Madman drummers, bummers, and Indians in
the summer with a teenage diplomat.
A cascade of words tumbling forward like
a river breaking its banks.
Same songwriter, a few years apart. What
made the later album better was a
radical act of subtraction. The
stripping away concentrated the music.
Picasso once defined art as the
elimination of the unnecessary.
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry put it this
way.
Perfection is achieved not when there is
nothing more to add,
but when there is nothing left to take
away.
A quote attributed to Lao Tzu goes even
further.
To attain knowledge, add things every
day.
To attain wisdom,
subtract things every day.
That is 2 and 1/2 thousand years ago.
Lao Tzu said it. Picasso said it.
Saint-Exupéry said it.
Lydi Son Ezra
lived it.
He hadn't been taught yet that when
something is broken,
you're supposed to add. If this video
sparked something for you, check out the
Hidden Brain podcast. You can find it on
any audio podcast player.
Each week, I bring you new updates about
the science of the mind and how the
hidden patterns in your behavior shape
your life.
Please check us out.
I'm Shankar Vedantam.
See you soon.